okay well it's fantastic and obviously
my my congratulations really are to the
people who've been campaigning in London
obviously we're very sad to have lost
some great London MPs tonight but you've
also seen extraordinary success by
conservatives in London in in Twickenham
my thinking in Kingston in Sutton these
are these rare frankly you know last
week I've been campaigning all those
areas I think thought I never thought
we'd win Twickenham it's absolutely
fantastic to see what's happening there
and clearly Kay tonight is an
astonishing night for the Conservative
Party if you consider where we were only
a few hours ago which was you know
looking at polls saying it was
neck-and-neck it turns out the British
people had the most amazing surprise up
their sleeve what happened what what
changed the polls do you think the pills
aren't usually this well I think it was
that I think it was I think it will know
the polls very often are completely
right but on this occasion the opinion
polls all 11 of them were totally wrong
in my view and I think it's because they
underestimated the great latent eminent
common sense of the British people when
faced with that choice do you want to go
backwards to failed 1970s style policies
of socialism under Ed Miliband or do you
want to go forwards with sensible
pragmatic inclusive one nation policies
that the Conservatives have been trying
to advocate that are going to take this
country forward and I think the mistake
of Ed Miliband that this is I imagine
the post-mortem will reveal is it he
basically vacated the centre ground that
Tony Blair hood squatted on with so
authoritative Lee he moved his party off
to the left and I think he's he's left
the field open / for a sensible
center-right party to develop policies
that are ready for the benefit of
everybody in the country and that I
think was the the [ __ ] okay and that
explains where we are today